la lave lundi dans le sous sol d'un sous
sol et des souvenirs s'agit moins de 19
ans c'est l'âge qu'avait alphonse martel
lorsqu'il est arrivé dans les tranchées
en corée 68 ans plus tard il se rappelle
encore le bruit de la première bombe qui
a sifflé au dessus de sa tête
au commencement de la guerre de corée
qu'on appelle aussi la guerre oubliée
éclater le 25 juin 1950 lorsque la corée
du nord communiste envahi la corée du
sud près de vingt dix mille soldats
canadiens ont pris part avec une
coalition de 16 pays des nations unies
par les mots du jeune homme que vous
étiez à l'époque déployés entre octobre
1952 et 1953
alphonse martel se rappelle de la
camaraderie avec ses frères d'armes de
sa fierté de servir son pays mais aussi
des conditions difficiles ca 9 mois
lundi et toulouse ont choisi un abri à
ses impôts pour deux ou trois soldats
on vivait là je faisais des trajets ou
la même en face d'avoir plaqué le gène
aux cris de façon régulière de façon
régulière dont je faisais à bombarder
célibataire est orphelin l'éloignement
ne pèse pas sur le jeune parachutiste du
22e régiment
quand j'ai rencontré mon futur moi je
pense
heureusement sa correspondance avec
claire une jeune québécoise qu'il
connaît à peine lui change les idées son
retour au canada
un amour naîtra de leur relation
épistolaire huit mois après le début de
la pandémie le plus grand sacrifice pour
ce vétéran qui de ne pas pouvoir passer
de temps avec son arrière petit fils de
six mois mais le militaire en lui n'y
est jamais bien loin pour relativiser
ces contraintes
moi j'ai établi suivant la demande
non suite à l'examen des rapports
confinement chez soi ce n'est pas une
mission à l'étranger
mais dans les deux cas être loin de ce
qu'on aime peut être vécu comme une
forme de sacrifice par certains et ce à
la caporale chef janie potvin leclerc
l'a constaté sur le terrain je peux
comprendre que pour les gens d'être
obligé de rester à la maison ne pas
pouvoir parler à leur famille militaire
depuis 13 ans la technicienne médicale a
entre autres soignées des collègues
blessés en afghanistan lors de son
déploiement en 2010 un travail qu'elle
fait fièrement mais qu'il a parfois
amenés à être séparée des siens pendant
de longues périodes
on sent un peu plus isolé parce que
justement nos familles sont pas proches
notre conjoint n'est pas là pour nous
supporter autant qu'on le voudrait mais
c'est les défis ça fait partie de ça
fait partie de la mission
c'est sûr que c'est un sacrifice pour la
famille mais je suis fier d'autres ça je
suis fier de servir mon pays
son expérience passée lui sert encore
aujourd'hui avec militaire on a
tellement une belle capacité de
résilience je pense que ça fait en sorte
que ces atouts l'heure c'est plus facile
doit passer à travers cette épreuve là
on est on est on est capable de
s'adapter rapidement
d'ailleurs le caporal-chef et
reconnaissant d'avoir pu participer à
l'opération laser dans les 6 h et celle
des durant la première vague de pouvoir
travailler avec des les civils des gens
de chez nous de pouvoir aider de prendre
soin des personnes âgées des personnes
âgées qui pourraient être nos grands
parents j'ai trouvé ça très gratifiant
pandémie ou pas alphonse martel et
jeanne hip hop et leclerc souhaite que
les militaires soient honorées en ce
jour du souvenir
c'est presque seule dame est arrivée il
écouter les contes et les malinois se
venger ou où surnagent arles déboires de
big c b j'ai dit quelque chose que ça
peut les influencer un peu plus que ça
va les aider à appliquer des champions
qui ont sacrifié leur vie des gens qui
sont venus de la gare blessé gravement
blessé autant physiquement que
psychologiquement c'est le temps de leur
rendre hommage d'avoir une petite pensée
pour eux une minute un moment pour leur
témoigner notre reconnaissance
ici valérie michaela bayne radio canada
montréal
[Musique]